hey everybody and welcome to a stellar
wild ride with stevo we've got bill burr
this guy is an icon he is a legend he's
a hero to me and he's always been so
nice and supportive of me
that i was really looking forward to the
day that i would get up the courage to
ask him to come on the wild ride podcast
and when i did he said absolutely and
man did we have a blast dude we laughed
so hard on this one and it really is a
lot of fun
kind of like
being at home and taking a dump at my
house
i love it man it's the one thing i can't
stand about being on tour is that i
don't have my hello tushy bidday
hellotushy.com
is absolutely my favorite sponsor of the
wild ride podcast and boy do they love
the listeners of it because if you go to
hellotushy.como
not only will you get 10 off your order
it's the tushy ace this is a whole
toilet seat that goes on your toilet
it the seat warms up it's got a remote
control when you get done pooping you
push the button and you've got a
refreshing
jet stream of water just pressure
cleaning your butthole and you can set
the water temperature to exactly the way
you like it
it's the most luxurious experience it
makes being at home so fulfilling for me
and again if you go to hellotushy.com
stevo you get 10 off plus this is my
favorite product i have ever promoted on
this podcast so jump on this deal and
let's get into it
hello sir
scarier than knocking on a van door
you're not
sure yeah dude
what's going on dude this is [ __ ]
cool what's up dude it's a
it was so difficult for me to
jump on the podcast bandwagon and become
the guy asking the question would you do
my podcast that the only way i could
wrap my head around it was to like oh
you were sweetheart yes she is
part shepherd
belgian malinois
street dog i found her in the streets of
peru
who would let this sweetie go
nobody even got her in the first place
were there other dogs that looked like
her in peru there were some there were
rather a few yeah
yeah
i was podcasting so forgive my outfit i
was going to dress up a little more oh
dude
not to worry i thought about giving you
a uh you know hey man are we still on
but i figured i just wouldn't at some
point i'm going to get an assistant
i just got my first
you know you know what my assistant is
is people reminding me i'm supposed to
be somewhere i'm like oh thank you stevo
for being my assistant today
all right yeah checking out i'm i'm
editing a movie right now right in there
nice so i'll be promoting that
shamelessly i love it throughout this i
love it
ladies and gentlemen bill burr what's
going on dude
um this is already my favorite podcast
to sit here petting a dog while doing a
podcast is the most soothing afternoon
ever
yeah
well it's it's an honor to have you man
i uh
was
an honor dude you're a legend
i'm happy to be here
you've been making me laugh for [ __ ]
20 years wow
i appreciate that so much man um i think
the last time we all saw each other was
uh in new york city you stopped by the
show oh caroline's yeah i was psyched
man i said
[ __ ] headlining caroline's that's a
huge one caroline's on broadway
it was out it was really cool that you
came over and i i've seen you since then
when um
comedy started to start back up and then
we had the outdoor should say what
parking lot did i run into right it's
like didn't you do a stunt out here
years ago
they uh set up um
in an alley in
hollywood boulevard not the magic castle
that was a good gig yeah i heard about
that one wasn't that one to drive in
well when they first had it they the
first time i did it
i hadn't done stand-up in like
oh man well march was when the [ __ ] hit
right lockdown and then we did the i
think i did that in like june or july
so
i i always wanted how people stopped
doing stand-ups like how do you stop
it's so fun how like do you know when
it's your last one right
so
when this pandemic hit remember in the
beginning everyone was like oh this is
just gonna be like you know about 14 21
days everybody stays inside yeah because
that's everything
the curve because everybody's going to
play ball and just listen to the people
no everybody did whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do which is also what makes this
country great so
uh
then all of a sudden i took a month off
i'm thinking i've been doing this [ __ ]
almost 30 years this is good to take
some time off and somewhere in may
i just stopped even thinking about stand
up just stop thinking about it because i
usually like i see something i'd be like
i'm going to talk about that that's
basically how i come up with
bits i see something i don't write it
down i just kind of go up and just
riff on the [ __ ] and hopefully it
turns into something and somewhere
around may like i stopped doing that and
i was watching like cooking videos and
[ __ ] like learning souffles or whatever
on the internet and i had this big
[ __ ] panic attack
like going like oh my god like i kind of
like through this virus have sort of
quit doing comedy so
anyway when the first one i did coming
back was that one at the magic castle
and it was outdoors which is always you
know weird you always if you're doing a
show outside you just automatically feel
like you're bombing because like all the
light all the laughs just go up into the
clouds and it doesn't come at you or if
there's like a roof you can feel like
okay they still like me let's see if
they like me after this one right sure
so that was all gone and they were like
in cars
no they handed they had those you know
those stupid things you go like this and
it's two hands clapping
so it's like these plastic things so you
tell a joke
out into this dark parking lot
and there would just be like this brutal
pause that felt like like a kick to the
chest and then you just hear a couple
but couldn't they just clap at that
point if they're holding a clapper like
what's the difference were they holding
them outside the window
if they're just told to do something
they do i guess you know nobody doesn't
people don't start to think
and then you have the other people who
think too much and then they start
thinking the world's flat but there's
there's there is a sweet spot yeah
you're on a show could be like or i
could just do this right and then they
were like they would flick their lights
they beeped but but what what i got out
of it
um it was funny it was a one show
adjustment by the second show
like those little tick tick tick tick
tick things i i i got in the mindset
like oh this is what killing sounds like
all right
or having a good set sounds like but
what i i got out of it was like
like the uh i was saying when i was on
there i go when this [ __ ] pandemic is
over and somebody says to you hey man i
am the biggest fan of stand-up comedy
you have to say oh yeah did you sit in
your ford focus in a [ __ ] parking lot
with plastic hands because you missed
hearing jokes i was like you guys
yeah you're like the people that went
through like the depression or the dust
bowl of like comedy you can say i was
there man i [ __ ] showed up where were
you
yeah weren't you relieved when the uh
were you touring when the um pandemic
happened and then you didn't have to get
on the plane you're like thank god i'll
tell you the one thing i did not miss
was lax for sure yeah i just i every
time i go into lax all it is is you just
want to get to your seat on the plane
and know that your bag
fit yeah and then it's just like okay
now
i have the amazing technology of travel
where i'm going to go across the country
what used to take people you know months
and they die and [ __ ] i'm gonna do this
for six hours i'm gonna [ __ ] complain
louis ck had a great bit about that
and um
but i never forgot that because i was
one of those people bitching on the
plane i saw louie one time on conan just
going dude you're in the [ __ ] sky oh
the internet doesn't work it's like yeah
yeah what you're like really did you
just fly
you used to have to like hike through
the [ __ ] mountains that we're just
flying over them you're just in there
jesus christ
you know i was totally one of those guys
it was one of like my favorite bits i
that i love and louis does this a lot
and guys at his caliber where it's they
sort of expose you
for the the [ __ ] you are and it's
it's those jokes are the best one you
buy yourself because you can't play it
off you just got to sit there like yeah
he's right
i'm 100 guilty of complaining
i complained about airports and
airplanes so much like i can't but after
the pandemic when we came back and we
had to wear the [ __ ] masks and and
just like after that break it it was so
much harder to get through an airport
and a flight
and they were like delayed more because
there was no
people flying i was a big mass guy dude
i loved them i'm down for them i loved
the mask i [ __ ] loved the mask
you like wearing it you like other
people wearing it like
i mean i i've given up on on on all of
that or whatever because i don't even
know if they even [ __ ] worked at this
point i mean but um but i was gonna
listen to some [ __ ] who has no
medical degree tell me they don't
[ __ ] work oh is that what your
[ __ ]
degree your lack of a degree tells you
it's just like so i'm gonna go
with the liars i know
rather than people that
you know know that they're being lied to
but then it's like well then now what do
i do now i'm gonna step off into the
wild
and just assume because someone got
kicked out of the medical field that
they were one of the good guys they get
not everybody who gets kicked out of the
medical field gets kicked out because
they're a good person and they're
telling the truth there is that yeah and
there's definitely you know
pharmaceutical companies synthetic
heroin all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that they
don't get called on killing a bunch of
people uh you know so i understood where
like that was coming from but like you
know i was in my emotions like everybody
else and you just wanted it to be over
and it was just like just do what they
say so at least we're all on the same
page so they can get some sort of
analytics to try to get us out of it so
i was into that for a while and then
after a while i was just like
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna sound like
the old man you know pick up your trash
i was just like all right i'm gonna do
what i you know i think everybody at
some point came to uh i'm gonna do
what feels right and then like that but
i gotta be honest i miss the mask
i miss it dude
dude you get out of so many [ __ ]
conversations like conversations become
quicker
and then you just get the [ __ ] out of
there and then there's like there's no
record of you really being there you're
always just walking around like you're
robbing a bank it was kind of [ __ ]
awesome i i i was in an airport
yesterday and i had two thoughts as i
walked in oh i don't have to wear a mask
but then i was
my next thought was oh but i'm about to
walk into like the hell of taking
pictures every [ __ ] five seconds and
i was like man i had a panic that i
didn't have my mask in my pocket
yeah i just want to cover my face yeah
it's like a kind of unfortunately don't
really have to deal with that
it's just good now yeah this guy's a
[ __ ] movie star man like i i have my
niche i got my [ __ ] jokes and the people
that like it and i'll just run into
somebody like hey that's you're that guy
right he's like yeah i like being at
that level i think with you though
people like might be timid to come up
because you might just roast the [ __ ]
out of them if they come wrong or
something like that yeah
i think that i think that i'm no i i
just tease people if they're being yeah
like i went to this thing the other day
right it was just this thing that was
disguised as a brunch it just turned out
to be this big marketing meeting it was
[ __ ] hilarious
so i'm sitting there and i'm eating this
lamb chop and this guy comes up to me
and starts talking to me and i just
looked at him i was like you know you
had three hours and 55 minutes to not
talk to me when i was eating a lamb shop
i'm gonna be here for four hours
can i just eat this thingy are you gonna
keep asking me right after i took a bite
he was another comedian he laughed and
he's a friend of mine and everything
like that but then of course he rolled
with me he's like no man i'm gonna talk
to you through this whole [ __ ] lamp
job then it became fun and it didn't
bother me because it became a bit
but if somebody's just doing it then
it's annoying so i found with people
like that i mean that you know
it's cool that they they they want to
talk to you and that type of stuff so
like you always have to be like okay
somebody could not be doing this but the
payoff then is i'm selling no tickets
and i'm back to that you know sitting in
that [ __ ] one-bedroom apartment with
my ikea furniture
yeah and all kinds of rug available for
yoga because i don't have any money
um so i would rather have this existence
but the happy medium of that selling
tickets right and living a great life is
wearing a mask
that's why i wish i was asian because i
could get away with it because they've
been wearing them for like the asians
[ __ ] man they've been wearing them since
[ __ ] stars they used to wear them on
the plane when they had a cold just
because they had a cold and the level of
considerate consideration i don't want
to give it to the rest of the plane
nobody does that it's amazing but if
you've ever been over to asia which is
incredible
is there so many people there that you
understand that that okay this is how
we're living so we we have that and i
think you know with every area of the
world you can learn something i'm kind
of like you know it would be cool
because i remember before the pandemic
when you get on a plane you see sitting
next to some guy he's just oh
and it'd be like it'd be great if this
guy was wearing
you're just saying like oh so this is
what my life's gonna look like in three
days
yeah
yeah dude
i i
love
that i've been able to graduate to the
tour bus and the theaters oh yeah
exactly
dude it's already you already don't have
a real job and then you get to travel
around like [ __ ] barry manilow he's
[ __ ] amazing
i'm dragging a piano behind you i say
this a lot that uh that i really believe
anybody who
claims that they're on the comedy club
circuit because they they love comedy is
is either lying or more mentally ill
than i am no i i took mushrooms and
figured out i finally figured out after
50 something years why i actually do
comedy like i thought i did it because i
i loved comedy and i realized no that's
not why i do it it was like it was the
easiest way to go into a room full of
people make them like you and then they
won't beat the [ __ ] out of you
[Laughter]
that was that was the subconscious
i need to make people like me so this
[ __ ] stops
yeah did do you travel with a tour bus
no i mean i have i have the only way to
make a tour bus work
i find is if you because you got to do
like a run of dates yeah so you got to
pay for the bus and then you do that
that stupid rock star thing because the
driver is like hey you want to take off
right after the gig you're like yeah
[ __ ] it let's get some of the driving
out of the way and you don't realize
that you're paying overtime yeah it's
like one time when my wife was uh
pregnant we're getting work done in the
house because we had to make a baby room
so we rented this house
and we [ __ ] heated the pool for the
whole [ __ ] month like idiots not
realizing how much it cost it cost me
twice as much what it cost to rent the
[ __ ] house so the tour bus can be
like that we're like oh yeah i paid for
it it costs this much you don't realize
there's over just so i just i go out
and um and if i can drive to another gig
because i still love driving um
i go out with uh club soda kenny and we
just we get like a like just like you
know suv and just cruise and then i like
you know hitting spots you know mom and
pop spots and [ __ ] like that and having
something to look forward to while i'm
out there so the guilt of not being
there with my kids but facetime helps
that so i never go out more than like
three four days but if i
was single and i or if i didn't have
kids
then i would get a cluster of cities
done yeah via tour but the great thing
about the tour bus is like it's a great
way to stay out of trouble you can get a
lot of trouble but if you use it right
it's literally like you just insulated i
go i do my show i come back i watch a
movie i hang with the other comics and
it's cool yeah the hell of the comedy
club grind
was the airports the airplanes the radio
stations and the hotels and the tour bus
takes all of that away
yes you just you just have a cozy little
pad which magically
just shows up where you have to do your
one hour of work oh no it's beautiful
it's beautiful i i i knew guys uh
that would literally have the tour bus
pull up to their house
they would pull up to their house like
all right honey see you later and they
just get on the bus they just have no
dates scheduled
no no no
they're going golfing yeah going golfing
around the country yeah no it's i um
yeah it's insane none of it makes sense
like how big comedy is right now i kind
of i think i figured out what but i i
think
the thing about it is is like it's not
like music where there's like genres
that have their time you know
like metal or or disco or or
grunge comedy people always want to
laugh so
i feel like as a comedian an old
comedian at this point i have to keep
going down to the store because the
young comics keep you young and comedy
does change like music but as long as
you're in it
you don't notice it you know it's like
watch you don't see yourself aging and
then you look three years ago it's like
[ __ ] what happened to me you know it's
the same thing like comedy if you're
down there every night it's changing
incrementally and you kind of get
dragged along with it and i found that
guys when they get to the the tour bus
theater thing you got to keep doing the
clubs because young comics
keep you young because uh i i can't it's
not a way it's not real way to explain
it but like i've i used to see you know
i've been this business so long i
remember the heyday of like sitcoms and
comics would get sitcoms and they they
would once they got to that third season
and looked like they were going to make
syndication you just see him less and
less at the club and the thing would go
like six seven seasons and all of a
sudden they didn't do stand-up for the
better part of a decade and then they
would come back
and like ray romano or something right
no ray always did it and that's why he
no i he's not special was so funny right
so great
and i used to watch guys like ray and
jerry and all of them they would keep
doing it but then i saw other guys i
won't name who didn't do it
and when they came back it was like they
had to learn how to do it again and and
they would be like
he would get super frustrated and they
would feel their age
and um like zoolander 2. yeah
that was a bad movie
i don't think i even saw it but i
believe you i never i never saw it yeah
you know in defense of the actors and
those things they usually don't want to
do the second one and then they go we'll
give you this nah man i just don't this
really we told the story nah man we'll
give you this
yeah you're going to give me the and
we'll give you then say all right [ __ ]
it i'll do it and then you get in there
and it's just like yeah all right i
always wondered if as you're making a
movie if you know it's bad
like because there's no way to tell
no because everybody on the crew is just
like that was so good and everybody's
kind of doing that and then it gets to
the theater and they're like it's a
great question and until it's cut
together like you don't know you know
like that felt like well we're doing
we're sitting right now outside
now i just asked bill that question and
he's gonna answer it by giving me the
information he wants me to know which is
a very sensible approach
now
in other areas of my life do you think i
want to be giving people information
that i don't want them to know because
that is happening left and right if you
are not using nord vpn vpn stands for
virtual private network what it does is
it disguises your location your ip
address so that people can't be snooping
around getting your private info your
passwords into your bank accounts all
that it's just crucial
cyber security 101 and on top of that by
using nordvpn
and changing your
your location on the internet changing
your ip address you can switch your
location to be in other different
countries and access all of the content
that those countries provide
let's say for example i want to enjoy
the better quality shows on british
netflix
boom nordvpn makes that super easy it
makes me safer it makes me happier and
it brings me joy by opening up a whole
world of content to me you'd be crazy
not to sign up for it and they've got an
exclusive deal for you the listeners of
the wild ride podcast
you go to
nordvpn dot com slash devo or just use
the promo code stevo at nordvpn.com
and you get a huge discount off of
nordvpn
plus you get an anti-malware
feature
and it's risk-free with the 30-day
money-back guarantee if you're not
totally satisfied
so jump on this man
get on over to nordvpn.com
stevo and feel safer and man watch
better tv all right what's bill burr up
to
i i shot a movie called old dads that i
wrote with uh
my writing partner uh
ben tischler and uh
first time i got to direct something i
was in the thing
and
we were just making it i just every day
i was saying to the producers like is
this good do you think it's good do you
think we have it yeah did we get this
scene and everything and
now that we're editing it we're almost
through the first editing but i gotta
tell you dude when you first look at the
assembly the fat cut especially at
comedy
this is basically the journey that you
go through it's like every day you do
six minutes is what we've been doing so
you come in and in the first six minutes
you sit there and look at the footage
and in the morning you think i just made
the worst movie hollywood has ever seen
i'm gonna be living with my parents but
and then somewhere around noon you're
like you start getting hope and by the
end of the day you're like dude this
movie's gonna be [ __ ] awesome we're
gonna do a whole bunch and then the next
day you come back in the next six
minutes you're like oh my god i made the
worst movie ever it just it just keeps
going through so i'm hoping when we go
to the second
um
when you do like 20 minutes a day you
can get through it quicker and i've been
talking to everybody that i i know that
are directors they go no dude it just
keeps tightening up and tightening up
and tightening up and i've been leaning
on them a lot and a bunch of friends of
mine and and i found that directors are
really really supportive really
supportive people yeah wasn't there that
martin scorsese quote when he's like if
your first cut doesn't
make you feel like you're a [ __ ]
complete disaster you're not on the
right track yeah or something like that
something like that yeah i talked to a
guy uh i worked on this thing i'm not
dropping any names but this is
a big actor and he made a movie that i
loved and he goes let me tell you
something about that movie he goes when
i saw the assembly of that thing he goes
i thought i ruined my career and he was
so like stunned of how bad it was when
he looked uh how bad he thought it was
because ended up being a great movie he
was riding the subway he was in new york
he was riding the subway and he had a
cut of the movie
next to him and he was just sitting on
the train this stunned look when he got
to his stop he was so [ __ ] in the head
he got off without the footage he just
left it he just walked off like
i said yeah
i did when i did the india thing the
first thing i saw i i was like i just
wasted all that [ __ ] money on this
dog [ __ ] how long does it take for you
guys
because your [ __ ] is so tight and it's
just bit bit yeah
and there's and every scene has like
[ __ ] eight guys in it and it's just
like oh my god does it go straight from
the shot to the editing bay or how does
that work
um
let's get into the minutia of editing i
think this is looking good
so when you have a dirty over what what
program are they using is that a stutter
cut there
they record on avid or they ended on
avid they i do believe it goes straight
in there and and we take our time we'll
we'll shoot for like
a week or two and then we'll just shut
down and they'll work on it so by the
end of it
we can be more targeted about what we're
even going to shoot like and then how
does it work with all of those guys
people got to be like dude you didn't
get my
[ __ ] backflip in there why why isn't
that oh dude i landed on those attacks
a personality in the film has not had
butt hurt moments where they really
really like third temper tantrum well
more like feelings tantrums well
what you guys do to your body the fact
that no one's gonna see it and it's like
so i did that for nothing so i can feel
that when i'm 80. yeah right
yeah just lost the testicle for nothing
yeah
i it it's insane what what uh so
this is a independent film
it's with miramax so yeah so we put it
together and then we do the dance to go
sell it so that's what it's going to be
cool as far as i know uh this is my
first
i'm usually just you know
the dancer monkey actor guy and they go
all right thanks a lot and right a year
later it comes out so now it's kind of
cool to go through
the whole process minus the the 1500
panic attacks i've had throughout
and this was your first time directing
like anything yes and there's a movie
like what yeah that's that's kind of a
daunting thing to help okay i had a lot
of help and i i
made you know and i came up with the
system that worked especially when i was
like uh
gonna be on camera on the scene
so like i i i mean actually being an
actor helped
because i hate when you if you do a
scene and after the first take the
director's already out there going you
miss this beat and this and make this
blah blah and then you do another one
and then they come out again by the time
the third take you're like nose blind
like i don't even know what this [ __ ]
thing is about so
we came up with this thing i i was
joking with everybody that i was like
you gotta let the horses run you gotta
let the horses run you gotta do three
takes of this thing
because everybody knows what they're
doing as far as actors but it's like i
don't know what you're gonna do so i got
okay you know okay so he's bringing that
i got i gotta have time to take in what
you're doing
and and you taking what i'm doing and
then after i found after like three was
the magic number as usual that it would
start to to get legs and then you could
start to guide it
and then um and then how you give notes
is the way you don't come in saying
you're not doing this you come in
positive you say okay that was great we
got that because
we got that as great when somebody's
completely the opposite okay we have
that version we got yeah yeah but all
the seasoned actors knew they were all
like going like oh she [ __ ] hated
that i was like no no no it's just i
need as many dude i'm gonna be in the
edit room i need as many options as i
can but like uh that was always hard
when he had a seasoned vet can you try
it this way and they'd be like well that
means you're not gonna use the other one
and i'm just like can you just
you directed it but you also acted in it
yeah
what's that like stupid
it was a stupid move how long were you
filming for it was but it but we it was
weird for like a week and a half and
then we had the system down and then
everybody just gelled and it was a uh it
was a really fun set everybody had a
good time and then i just kept getting
food trucks to keep just keeping
everybody happy
um is the way to go which is great when
you grow up in like a volatile
environment you learn how to keep people
chill yeah
[Music]
helps out or you know
so yeah that's kind of what we did and i
think
yeah we're dealing with [ __ ] right now
that i'm gonna have to go deal with
that's cool so this is a nice break for
you to not look at the screen for a
while
yeah was that how it is oh got a dog
production like kind of post
pandemic wait
is this
she's purring she's snoring
oh my god can i please get audio of that
i'm gonna go to sleep to that
i call that purring
oh my god she's like the dog in the
[ __ ]
bugs bunny yeah not the dog i mean the
the frog but it wouldn't sing when you
wanted to you know what i love about
dogs is they remind you that you need to
sigh a lot during the day
they do it all the time i saw the dog do
that my dog unfortunately passed away a
little while ago but uh i gotta once the
kids get bigger we're gonna get them and
i always love that about dogs is even
though they're lying down and chilling
and not doing nothing they still
everyone smile just go
i'm just like you're right buddy you're
right i always feel like they're
reacting to my energy like
they were all the [ __ ] dog owners i
had to get this
it's like an eye roll i got a good 10 to
15 years
i'm supposed to be living a dog's life
and i got this guy with wall street
[ __ ] energy walking around the house
yeah i'm a particularly needy dog owner
where
she's like oh this [ __ ] guy yeah no
but dogs dogs need a needy owner
i feel like strong people get cats as
much as people who have cats
like
dog people uh you know
i'd say strong slash reptilian cold
people kind of like cats
yeah because you get less love from a
cat like the dog is to love you yeah
because you need it oh yeah and it helps
you know yeah the cat is like you gotta
be good without the cat dogs are the
breeders man you come home you [ __ ]
flip out it's awesome they're the best
cats you can be dying and they just like
[ __ ] just walk away from your body
and if you die and no one comes in there
they start eating you yeah do that
there's no food yeah wow is that like a
thing that is a thing
because i know uh i ran into i ran into
somebody i went to high school with
and they were like you remember old man
so-and-so was like yeah he died they
came in the cat ate half his face and
i'm just like hey man good to see you
i guess you really never can't go home
yeah dogs will like run over and pick up
the phone and dial 9-1-1 and like you
know pound on your heart yeah they'll
jump jump through the window
cut themselves
okay i got a random question i i was
like really thought about secure
genuinely curious if you've ever
apologized for a joke
i was legitimately nervous to ask that
question i'm genuinely scared
and i'm also
very nervous about what i'm about to
share right now it's uh sensitive
information but i'm so proud i just have
to blurt this out last night for the
first time in my over five-year
relationship with lux
she came twice in one bone sesh is that
something i mean unbelievable so what's
the secret to my success with my sex
life with lux i'm just gonna go ahead
and say
bluetooth tablets baby what are
bluetooth tablets they're delicious they
have the same active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis except they only cost
a fraction of the price they give you
a
super boner
super sex like the sex i had with lux
last night yeah dude man now of course
you have to have a prescription to get
this i mean
i think everybody knows that but what's
so great about bluetooth tablets is that
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office or anything like that you simply
consult with the medical provider at
bluechew.com
it's very quick it's very easy and your
bluetooth tablets are on the way plus
here's the great news
for the listeners of the wild ride
podcast if you use the promo code stevo
bluechew.com you get an entire month's
supply of bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping again that is an
entire month's supply of bluetooth
tablets which i love with all of my
heart absolutely for free all you got to
pay is five bucks for shipping so jump
on it and have fun bonin
now
let's see how this question goes over
yeah yeah yeah but i do it to an the
individual that i heard if i was if
listen if i'm in a bad mood
okay now some asshole's going to cut
that right there so you can should
apologize because that's everybody's
like fox news and cnn
no if i'm in like a bad mood
and like
or if i did if i told a joke about
something that somebody had a personal
effect when i and i made him sad or made
him cry
you know there's that comic to move [ __ ]
you lady you shouldn't come out like i
don't take it to that level it's just
like
yeah you're right you know i didn't i
didn't think of that i didn't know you
were going to be here tonight what are
the [ __ ] odds you were at that thing
that i was making fun of you know i mean
but that can happen but what i think is
i i refuse to apologize
to anybody that is upset that they that
they heard a joke at a show they weren't
at
you know especially if somebody film
okay if it's in my special that's
different i decided to like put it out
or whatever
um
but like
you know if it's one of those things
where someone in the crowd films you and
then they put it up it's like get mad at
them and you
because you you saw the subject and you
clicked on it so i mean that's that's
you had all of these other [ __ ]
things they have like
they they have videos of just dog
snoring that you could watch
and feel good about your day but you
went out of your way to [ __ ] watch
this thing it's on you well the fact
that it's showing up in their algorithm
means that they're [ __ ] already in
the the energy field of all those videos
and that's something i love to do
blaming the victim
well what were you watching if you saw
it yeah
yeah how did it pop up no i i i am uh
i'm a big believer and if you are wrong
and you feel you're wrong you apologize
but i'm not
a believer in the mob mentality and i'm
now going to apologize just to because
it's not worth it because then all i do
is give that
strength that that's okay to do that and
then some other comics gonna have to
deal with it so
um yeah so like yeah if you come up to
me after a [ __ ] show i mean i i'll
listen to you and i'll be there and if i
agree with what you're saying i'll be
yeah all right okay
i [ __ ] up i'm sorry yeah yeah it
wasn't a personal thing i'm sorry i'm
sorry you went through that or whatever
and i found you can like actually
they'll be cool with you in the you know
people like anybody like us we want to
be heard
so but as far as that that you know that
professional being offended so you can
move whatever cause
because you feel like you can fix
society you know with your ideas i mean
i i don't i don't get into that yeah
okay what do you enjoy doing better tv
shows or movies
or stand up i will tell you this it was
a long time ago it used to be movies but
now tv shows are
is are so badass
speaking of which wearing a credit here
reservation dogs yeah i i had a blast
doing that um uh
breaking bad chappelle show i thought i
i
made it that way i feel like yeah uh i
would say the wire before that
uh sopranos yeah hbo and and dexter
basic cable was the thing that showed
like all of a sudden like
you know you can go to this level and
i'm still waiting for the sitcom
to uh
to get to that level and i feel like
there's always been like a glass ceiling
on how funny you can be
in front of a live audience like at a
sitcom because the the suits get all
nervous
with any sort of thing that isn't like
you know just a fastball
you know good american values right over
the plate and um that's why i was really
rooting for when norton and um
louie did uh louis sitcom like i thought
what louie was doing
was gonna like hopefully break jay moore
a long time ago did a great one um that
peter he played peter dragon what the
hell was it um
he played this producer and that was on
fox
and that was another one that i thought
sort of ex but that was more of a one
camera but that sort of expanded
to like
you know
okay people are adults they know what's
phony now
so they want to see something that's
real or absolutely absurd i feel and uh
especially because now the average
person on youtube is making a video and
then they read comments so even they in
a way are like in an editing bay and
they learn what
plays and what doesn't and they actually
know what it in a small way what it's
like to make something creatively and
bomb and have it have it get zero stars
and uh
you know and have all those awful
feelings
um
how was it to make like f is for family
you're able to like let a joke breathe a
lot more than like a sitcom right or a
tv show yeah and uh and netflix was
awesome because their thing was when
we did it
i remember when we when they read the
pilot episode they were going like yeah
push it further and that was like the
dream note that you were waiting for but
like that was and that was one of those
things like mike price
uh from the simpsons he's the co-creator
and the and the showrunner he was he was
the captain of that ship so i could only
take so much credit he like if you like
f is for family mike price
is the reason why you like it because
all of that stuff that i had to do on
this movie now i already respected mike
but now i haven't done this i'm like oh
my god like the amount of questions that
this guy has to answer
um that i didn't and the amount of
decisions that he had to make so um and
then also you know vince vaughn when you
know when i pitched doing an animated
show it'd been a while
since like uh comedians had done like an
animated show like howie mandel and luis
and louis anderson rest of seoul had had
done those and they you know this
industry is really like what's happening
now so someone hadn't done one in a
minute so i think me pitching a cartoon
was weird but uh vince vaughn got behind
it and was sitting there in the pitch
meeting so when they were looking at me
like why does this idiot want to do
a cartoon they'd be like oh my god
that's an a-list movie star
it's fun he believes in it so i i always
felt like peter billingsley and vince
vaughn i gotta make sure i say
everybody's name that got that thing
going um they were the reason why that
that thing
got on the air and then i just
you know i mean i literally learned how
to write a script on that thing
i learned how to do three different
takes of a line all of that [ __ ] that i
didn't know because i came up as a
comedian i'm like i tell the joke this
is how i tell it if it bombs i move on
to next thing
um
was that the idea with comedy like you
got in the comedy to do acting or did
you just only want to be a comedian and
it kind of just happened
i always want to be a comedian comedian
i i all the communities that i loved
became great comics obviously you know
those ones that i watched and then they
they
they got picked up on stuff yeah like
you know richard pryor eddie murphy uh
cheech and chong all of them and then
they would go into movies and i was
really
watching um
and then you'd see other people
that they get a shot and because they
were in comedy clubs and didn't take
enough acting classes when they got
their shot you know you'd get your shot
and if you didn't it's not like today
man back then when you got your shot
that was your shot
and if you didn't get it dude like you
got put all the way to the back of the
line dude and i'm telling you had to
wait like seven eight years you had to
wait for studio execs to die or get
fired
it's okay to go back in that building
again because they're gonna be like oh
yeah we tried something with you and it
didn't work you're the it doesn't work
guy
um so you just stayed in comedy for a
while
no i started taking acting classes early
on um yeah it was always acting in
comedy yeah
well i remember i ran into a comedian
and he was one of these guys that that
uh he was a young comic and a redhead i
think
i think that was him yeah a long time
ago and he told me a story like you know
i went down to new york and he had this
look on his face and he goes dude i went
up and i killed and there was some head
of nbc was there and they were like dude
you're so castable and they brought me
in they gave me a script and i didn't
know what to do with it and the way he
told the story
i i just never forgot he's like dude my
biggest advice to you forget all this
this comedy stuff just keep doing it but
like take acting classes along the way
so when you get your shot
um
you know you don't blow it yeah you
don't blow it so
thank you to him that's good
um i saw something where uh you said
that you learned how to fly a helicopter
because you looked into the banking
system
am i wrong i mean what's going on right
now yeah you almost got your motorcycle
right like i was on a [ __ ] airplane
sitting flying across the atlantic to
london
sitting next to a guy who was on the u.s
rowing team going he was going to go
compete in [ __ ] finland how shredded
was his back
seven
and he's sitting there reading this book
by neil strauss called uh like [ __ ]
how to survive some survival guide thing
and i was interested because neil
strauss wrote the motley crue book and
he's like this epic writer what's going
to say talk about a wide variety right
i guess it's all about survival if
you're talking about motley crue
these guys somehow survived
motley
so this guy
explains what the book's about he's like
oh well in in the case of natural
disaster or economic collapse or you
know nuclear or whatever like and there
was just in a whole variety of scenarios
which represented
[ __ ] hitting the fan and the first thing
you gotta do is get the [ __ ] out and he
said that this guy recommended
motorcycles because you could split
lanes to get out that's great it's a lot
cheaper than a helicopter license
but but uh it's just so dude so i turn
around and like the next i only have a
too so i'm going to make a sophie's
choice
who's coming who's staying live
i uh i turn around and [ __ ]
enroll in motorcycle school because that
because i bought onto the idea of this
you know that's cool though but then you
learn something i know but here's the
[ __ ] thing dude like what did you
write
as soon as i enrolled in motorcycle
school and i enrolled and there it's
going to be like another weeks before i
actually have the the classes
as soon as i enrolled every single
[ __ ]
everywhere i went someone's like oh i
get to go visit somebody in the hospital
they were like you know are they [ __ ]
motorcycles
motorcycles just kept coming up in
conversation and it was always the worst
[ __ ] thing and then when i got there
to the actual class i realized that like
you gotta have like a clutch on the
motorcycle and i've never even learned
how to drive stick in my life so while
they're trying to teach me i'm like oh
well
[ __ ] you know like you gotta remember
the clutch and you know it just delays
your reaction time and and already like
i'm just like i'm a dead duck i can ask
you a question
when you were in the cause i took the
motorcycle safety course and i got my
license and all that i wrote for like
two months and someone else took my head
off going over the double line in a turn
and i remember like coming back i was
running a triumph bonneville and i was
literally shaking
and i would and it's funny because i
never pray
so i dial up god for the first time in
years and it's like oh look who called
what do you want bill
[Music]
just to say hi do you
this [ __ ] guy
puts me on speaker
[ __ ] right so i [ __ ] um
i just said if you let me get back
to dean delray's garage without losing
my leg or my life i swear to god i'll
never ride this [ __ ] thing again and
i didn't but now i kind of got it back
again and i'm thinking of getting like a
dirt bike just to ride around i
fly to this little little ass airport
and i'm just just gonna ride around
there where it's safe so i still have
the skill yeah so i know how to do it
because i think that they're they're
[ __ ] badass man i i but when you took
the class didn't you look at a couple
people just being like why this person's
going to die right i remember that that
was steve they were like
it was a three-day class the the first
day was in a classroom the second day
was in a parking lot and the third day
was in the parking lot and i [ __ ]
quit after the
the first parking lot day i'm a
motorcycle school dropout
now it didn't it didn't just could have
just completed because you would have
got i know but but here's the here's the
thing and then you know how to do it you
don't have to run i almost shouldn't say
this but but after my
first day in the parking lot actually
riding the motorcycle i had a date
later that night with like
i didn't want to say anything i'm
[ __ ]
really like
she was like
voted by maxum magazine like the seventh
hottest woman on the planet
the next day to get up and the next day
you have to go to class
and when she asked if i wanted to meet
her dogs
i
did and i never left
that's a good excuse for not
completing that's all right some of the
hottest woman in the world and he blamed
it on like motorcycle accidents and
death i i said you know what i'm not
going to go to motorcycle class that
[ __ ] was going to [ __ ] kill me those
guys ride motorcycles so they can meet
that [ __ ] you like pre-emptiness
yeah all i'm going to do is get road
rash in my dick
yeah wow
looking at the stats i just don't think
it's right
it's not safe
and then you just raw dog the random
thing
safer than riding a motorcycle
it's a lot safer
the uh the how often do you fly your
helicopter well what sucks is right now
because i'm involved in this i'm not
allowed to fly okay they're like they'd
say okay you can try and kill yourself
after we get a cut of them
of the movie so
um i haven't flown since uh february
right before uh because i didn't realize
that but i mean i went up with an
instructor or whatever so uh i'm like
you know really safe and those
you know
as my instructor says aviation is as
safe as you are and you would be
surprised like that there's only two
types of pilots pilots that know they
can die and then the other people who
just show up like i mean [ __ ]
pre-flight
just [ __ ] cranking and just take off
you look at their whole attitude when
they take off it's like dude if you have
an engine failure right now you're just
gonna nose into the ground or you see
people like flying super low flying
really slow it's like you're dead if
your engine dies you don't have enough
altitude to regain your air speed to
keep this [ __ ] thing going to go into
a flare like an auto rotation and you're
[ __ ] dead so they there's like
you know with anything dude there's like
these major
things that if you implement them you
look at the weather you do your prefer i
only fly when it's nice out i only fly
up to a certain knots of of winds
because i mean i mean i can fly in it
but why do i want to be up there [ __ ]
bumping around and everything
and you know you can you can get the
odds
in your favor and now like you should
see like i'll show it to you something
like the cockpit i have all glass
cockpit and i'm literally like an air
traffic controller now with the uh with
the technology where you can back in the
day
when i first started flying like you
were just talking to people you didn't
know where anybody was it was just them
reporting so if you went out you know
east day here where all these [ __ ]
yahoos are who aren't they don't even
talk on the radio and all of a sudden
i'll go flying by you and you're like
dude what the [ __ ]
now you can see them coming you can
literally like put your finger on the
screen and their tail number will show
up and you can talk to them the arrow
points in what direction they're going
there's a thing that says plus six minus
five i mean 600 above you might so you
know exactly where the [ __ ] they are is
that bad for drug smugglers
i got a good one for you uh instructor
told me uh you know when when any time
the vice president or the president
comes in town there's just a massive tfr
wherever they are
without uh temporary flight restrictions
you're not allowed to fly in there and
if you do you're warned and then you get
intercepted by like a [ __ ] i don't
know what you know an f-16 which
wouldn't work with the helicopter
because you fly so slow they'd have to
keep going bias so they probably sent
some sort of presidential level uh
secret service helicopter up there
um
there was a guy uh flew into a tfr
didn't do his pre-flight and that's one
of the things you do you look to see if
there's because you get major [ __ ]
trouble if you fly into one of those
even if you just fly over dodger stadium
two hours before the game yeah there's
two hours before the game and after
because there's gonna be all of those
people they just you know don't fly over
that if you fly into that the faa is
calling your tail number i mean i don't
know what happens i don't want to find
out what happens so this [ __ ] idiot
did not check
and he flew right into it and he wasn't
on the radio and he got intercepted and
they landed and it turned out it was a
drug smuggler coming up from mexico
which usually then you're not going to
be on the radio but at least
fly around the [ __ ] and they forced him
down and he had a whole plane full of
drugs and that was it and if he had just
looked at his tfrs he could have still
been bringing cocaine into this country
yeah you can't even fly a drone over
daughter stadium during the game where
you go to jail i mean it's pretty did
drone over dodgers during the game no
dude there's a guy and they can't find
him and i don't understand why the guy
has a [ __ ] jet pack
yeah and he's he's been hovering
right outside like every couple of
months he'll just be there
at dodger stadium no at lax and he's
he's sitting there like he's at [ __ ]
buck rogers
so my thing is like how many people buy
jet packs like we can't get some people
on this so the funniest [ __ ] ever that's
online you have to listen to the radio
calls
is there talking to somebody flying in
anywhere from three to six hundred
people
yeah just let you know after the left
you got a guy in a jet pack and then the
pilot's like yeah we see him
and everybody sees this [ __ ] and he's
just
and yeah they don't know who he is right
it's like a mystery i don't understand
on what black market this guy bought
this [ __ ] jet pack
because i remember i was watching the
first 48 one time and this [ __ ] idiot
bought a 50 caliber desert eagle and i
guess not a lot of people have them and
they killed somebody with them and they
just went all right who bought a desert
eagle they had it was like you should
become the first 48 minutes
they [ __ ] caught this guy
in like an hour that's the best show
ever
yeah well i i got a buddy of mine former
cop hates that show because i was
watching that show going i don't
understand why they keep talking i'm
like all you do is say am i being
charged with anything if i am if i want
a lawyer if not i'm leaving he goes
that's why i hate that show because it
teaches dirt bags how to beat the system
the worst one i ever saw was they
brought this guy and they go and there
was some old guy that was got murdered
in the park then they say to this guy
it's a suspect and they go
they go hey do you know old man johnson
or whatever
he's like yeah yeah i know him he goes
you're good friends with him because
yeah i see him around he goes uh
well uh i hate to tell you this but we
uh we just found him in the park he was
murdered and the guy just worst acting
ever he stands like what oh man
i didn't do it
just sign the confession and you just
literally watched a guy
it takes somebody's life away and just
throw their whole life it's like that
guy's going to jail for the rest of his
[ __ ] life he should have taken an
acting class because when his moment
came he would have been ready to watch
the first 48. yeah
[ __ ] lawyers you ever you ever see
that picture of the ramirez brothers
courtside like an hour before the
menendez
like the twin brothers or whatever
there's like a picture of them at a
basketball game sitting courtside
everybody's like cheering and they're
just like straight faced
it's an eerie [ __ ] picture and
they're like this was like two hours
before they murdered their parents
is that weird
it'd be weirder if they were like stoked
and like cheering and happy you know
yeah that just reminded me of you
remember in scarface
when there's the comedian on stage and
everybody's cheering and all of that
stuff and everybody's watching and
tony's cooked in the corner everybody's
dying laughing to palma just pans across
and there's two people just sitting
there
like that and the ones with the oozies
under a napkin i love the oozies under a
napkin like at some point they just took
them out and then put
would you like something to drink hang
on a second let me just put this right
here
where's like let me get that napkin like
no no don't touch the napkin leave the
napkin did you see that clip going
around with amber heard snorting coke on
the uh
yeah
i mean i get my news from tmz and they
said that was absolute [ __ ] did you
see it though
i have not been she looks like she's
watching that
yeah you see this she definitely did not
do cocaine on the stand no
yeah i don't know but she's that crazy
i'm not talking out of school because
the guy put it in his book if you want
to see somebody doing cocaine on tv
during a super bowl
uh thomas hollywood henderson
of the uh dallas cowboys you have to
read his book his book is [ __ ]
unbelievable the guy was doing he was
basically lawrence taylor before
lawrence taylor because of drugs he
messed up his career so that's why
lawrence taylor looked like he fell out
of the sky like there was nobody there
was no like link you know like the bands
it's like this band did this then they
did oh that's where they came from it
was like lawrence taylor just came from
outer space but like like hollywood
henderson was a linebacker you like
returned like a
like a kick off to open like uh super
bowl 10. like nobody did that [ __ ] and
he almost got a touchdown
and um he was doing coke in the 70s
before people knew how to do cokes it
was just raw
he was like cutting it up with like a
matchbook or something and like his
[ __ ] nose was so [ __ ] he had a hole
in his nose
yeah so what he would do before a game
was he would just pack his nose with
cocaine so it was numb
and then he would go out and play
and then during halftime he'd be blowing
his nose as tom landry the straightest
lace guy ever with like a fedora look
like he was on like dragnet would be
telling him what to do in the half and
he would be in there blowing his nose
and then repacking it
with cocaine so anyway when the second
time the cowboys played the steelers in
super bowl 13. he had cocaine and water
and remember those vic's things when you
had a cold and there's footage of him
going like that and then people think he
has like hay fever or something he's
actually [ __ ] blowing lines in the
rose bowl
during the super bowl
damn you ever just pack your hole with
cocaine back in the day
i discovered that i had the whole
uh it's called a deviated septum and i
discovered it when i was in the psych
ward
like days after my intervention and so i
just fortunately
have been clean and sober ever since
then how did you discover i just thought
you went to an ears nose and throat
doctor when they flashed a light up this
nostril it came out the other side
i've taken pictures while i put the
flashlight on on my cell phone and stick
the flashlight in one nostril and
[ __ ] it really does that yeah you can
see you got the hollywood bowl spotlight
coming out the other
yeah
it's crazy but i just i forget how but
uh but once i discovered it like
i i managed to thread my nose with the
shoelace
knoxville came to visit me in rehab the
glass is always half full
this is really sad or
new
and opportunity it's pretty cool yeah
that's gonna be a lot of cocaine used to
burn a hole through your nose right yeah
yeah i i didn't [ __ ] around man i
i i i was pretty strong in the in the
drugs department um well hey dude
[ __ ] like uh tell us again about this
project that you're editing oh so yeah
it's just it's a comedy it's called old
dads it's just about guys my age that
have kids later in life
and then you go to school and it's like
your kids in kindergarten and you were
in kindergarten 50 years ago but your
brain goes back to that's the way it is
and how everything's changed and uh
it's just it's a simple
comedy formula
but it's
it's not done
it's like my act
so it's definitely rated r
you know his dad's in the title but i
think uh i think people are going to
like it
and and when's that
projected to i don't know i'm i'm
supposed to like this whole summer i'm
just living with the thing and uh i'm
actually enjoying editing which i didn't
think i just you know i got massive
[ __ ] add
and uh so i had to fight the whole no
this takes looks good it's like no we
have to watch all the takes right let's
piece it together and i'm just sitting
that [ __ ] you know nervous [ __ ]
legs restless leg syndrome watching it
but now i'm i've settled into like
that's what it is and that's what's
gonna fix this
any problem that i'm gonna have in it so
i've just i just sort of
i gave into it you know i'm drinking
coffee now i never drank coffee in my
life and just every once in a while i'm
just like
you know when you have your head in the
oven it's just like i suck and then you
drink it's like no i'm awesome
let's get this going
and you're uh you're touring but just
not like just a few days at a time yeah
i go out you know just a couple two
three days and uh
yeah and then i come back hang with my
kids and you know i try to edit while my
my kids are at school and then and then
i'm uh
you know it's
it's a little bit i come home a little
bit after
they've gone to school but then i have
that last two hours of crazy time with
them every night
and uh it's funny dude like how they
view me i didn't even realize that my
father-in-law
was uh was in town he's the best dude i
really lucked out with my my in-laws
they're [ __ ] really cool people
and he was just like laughing because
i'm in the living room and it's just
like they just like they just jump on me
flying elbows and just you know coming
off the couch and stuff and uh you know
yeah i'm definitely i think i'm more
like the my my wife is the one
like she like throws down the gauntlet
uh when and she's really good at it
and i i it takes a lot
like i have one tone of voice that i go
to that they actually listen to me
everything else they're just like ah
shut up dad
i've kind of lost some credibility i
don't know if you can get that back
we'll see do they have any concept of
like your career or like what you do yet
um not really and i i don't like
you know i don't
like bring that i don't have like
[ __ ] posters or shows or anything
there's nothing in the house that says
yeah that i do but you know my daughter
knows what i do but i don't want to
watch my act
um but like obviously but like
uh
like my son has no concept but my my
daughter like knows but like
you know i just have to explain to her
when i go on the road
like this is why we can go to chuck e
cheese and go skateboarding
the man has me running on the wheel okay
i'll explain that to you when you get a
little older yeah okay that's great man
i think
the uh
you know like uh i i saw the the
your
the accolade from rolling stone of being
the heavyweight champ of rage
comedy yeah and uh
and i think it's just it's just that's
someone who just watched clips before
they had to write that
right before they went out and hooked up
with the seventh hottest woman in the
world
what i got to write about this bald
orange i love that i i love that and uh
and i just felt i find it ironic because
you're the nicest guy you know yeah and
the perception if you watch two minutes
of my act is that i walk around
like i mean i was definitely
a very angry man when i was in
uh
my 30s when i was in my 20s i didn't
understand i was still like hey you know
whatever you want to do i want to do it
oh i love this guy he does whatever so i
had this
weird
phase and then in my 30s as my life
wasn't coming together the way i thought
it was going to which is you know what
you're supposed to be doing i'm at this
age i should be here
like the only thing that was working was
my stand-up and everything else was
still like at the starting line
so i definitely went through uh
that period but like
i kind of undid it in my 40s and in my
50s like uh
yeah i mean i'm
i'm a pretty simple person like i'm not
there's not too many layers to me like i
swear to god if i have like a sandwich
in a [ __ ] little cigar in an
afternoon i mean that's it i mean what
the [ __ ] more do you need in life so
um i'm lucky that my wife understands
like that too because i was telling you
know there's that disease in this
business
and just or just any business that if if
as you're selling more tickets or doing
better in your job and you're making
more and more to buy more and have like
a bigger life or it's like or i could
just [ __ ]
be happy with what i have not buy any
more [ __ ]
and then someday when this business is
done with me and it kicks me to the curb
i didn't blow all my money on on right
dumb [ __ ] and i can like uh
you know still eat some scrambled eggs
and not have to panhandle
yeah
i'm not into any flashy [ __ ] really i
mean
i i like to have a cool podcast man but
oh dude this is sick i uh my tour bus um
is a piece of [ __ ] rv
like oh yeah
you know you know the one i wanted to
buy the one from stripes
that gmc made with the six wheels i
always wanted to redo one of those and
there's one that's the the it's the palm
desert package or something and it's
like two total ron burgundy it's that
[ __ ] 70s green with the floral like
captain's chairs and a green shag rug
and i was just thinking man
if i ever [ __ ] redid one of those put
a humidor in there with some cigars and
[ __ ] oh moving cigar lounge oh my god oh
my god mobile cigar lounge yeah sick i
know but then you gotta watch because
then then all your demons
are just right there
yeah yeah that's another thing too i
learned that's when my drinking got out
of control was when i brought it home to
the house
and then i could oh there's a i don't
have to go out to a bar because before
like i always had it under control
because i had to go out you know if i
felt like getting a drink but i was at
home and i was watching a game
in your sweatpants it's like dude i
don't want to [ __ ] take a shower and
[ __ ] go out and do all of that [ __ ]
so then you just wouldn't drink and then
it wouldn't get a hold of you but when i
had it at home
yeah i had this thing where um part of
conspiracy theory you know
you get massively overwhelmed and
depressed when you're reading that [ __ ]
um
so how i i then i after i got out of the
conspiracy theory [ __ ] i went the other
way and i started watching like me tv
and all these old [ __ ]
shows from when i was a kid and
everybody on those shows drank and
smoked so i would just sit there they
were drinking i was just i was drinking
with like ephram zimblis jr like every
[ __ ] night watching 77 sunset strip
and uh and you know it was started off
with this then it became that
then my wife started getting on me like
jesus christ through the signs and i
started i go it's a home poor i started
you go out to a bar they take out the
eye droplet it's just like that's not a
[ __ ] drink
and then i remember one night i came i
told this story before i came down the
stairs because she goes don't have
another one when you have three you
start snoring like your dog here so
i was like all right all right and then
i was like i just have two i can just
have two right and then i was just like
you know there's still you know eight
minutes left in the show i'll pour
another one so i poured the other one it
was over and i was walking down the
stairs to our bedroom and i didn't know
if she was still up or not i literally
was hiding it
on the side of my leg
trying to make sure the ice cube wasn't
gonna clink against the side of the
glass and i was just like i am like this
close away from having a bottle in the
back of the toilet let me let me just
step away from this [ __ ] so
um i'm not like an alcoholic you know
what i mean but i do think that
addiction is like is more of a spectrum
than you either are you aren't and i
think that if you're a habit guy like me
no different than sugar and salt like i
never craved mcdonald's unless i was in
a jam and i ate it and then for like the
next three days like i see the golden
arches everywhere like dude i'm gonna
get a [ __ ] another double
cheeseburger man so
yeah i smoked a cigar and then i was
like man are these bad for you then i
looked up i was like how many cigars did
george burns smoke a day and it's like
10 to 15 i'm like great i can do two a
day you know it's like it's so easy
there's no way there's no way he smoked
10 to 15 at that why google told me that
i don't know i know and if you know who
put that information out there a cigar
smoker that's trying to get his wife off
his back
he smoked 15 a day christ i'm a
lightweight yeah i'm only smoking seven
yeah
yeah dude
well hey man let's get you back into
your edit base so you can be with your
kids that was fantastic yeah thank you
for having me yeah dude i'm really happy
for all you yo you've already had
success but like to see you like i was
so psyched when i saw you with
caroline's i was telling my wife like
[ __ ] steve i was playing caroline's i
mean when he was like starting out you
know he just got sober and all that so
i'm really happy for all of you i
appreciate that yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome and your dog rules yes she does
all right guys thanks for having me
thanks brother all right look at that
she slept through the whole thing
what do you say to that i mean come on
it's uh
so cool dude sat down one of the first
things he said is that i'm a legend you
kidding me that guy is
i mean what
anybody in the world top three i mean
greatest comedians alive
dude
so stoked on
just knowing that guy let alone like
having such mutual respect
dude what a bro i'm really really stoked
on that one and as you know i'm really
really stoked on you for sticking around
to the end of the wild ride podcast
what can i tell you that uh
[Music]
that's
special
okay
i might have drummed up a
new collab
skateboard design for me and my bro we
man okay
you heard it here first
it's the [ __ ] dopest design of all
the skateboards i've designed this is by
far the dopest design i can't wait for
everybody to see it um and [ __ ] thank
you so much yeah dude